- I love chaos, I'm doing 800 things.
- But you didn't start doing 800 things.
- That's right, and any
time I know I'm about
to do something, I did
Vayner Media head down
for five years to build a
foundation to do things.
- [Guest] Right, I
always tell people this.
(hip hop beat)
- Hey everybody it's Gary Vee, Ner Chuk
and this is episode 304
of the Ask Gary Vee Show
and I'm really excited for this next guest
and we're coming in super cold.
Nick D on my team said hey,
I think Strauss should be
on your show, and I'm like 100%.
Being invited to a Strauss party
maybe nine years ago in the tech,
kind of media scene was
a super highlight for me.
And some of you who know me know that
Ben Ler is a very good friend of mine
and earlier that, like
three months earlier
than that party, Ben and I, you know
how like guys or gals get into like a meme
of something that's funny to them?
Somehow a movie called Ghoulies
became this really funny thing,
you know that movie?
(talking off screen)
Was it, I thought it
was like a horror movie.
- [Strauss] It was a horror movie.
Yeah it was a little bit of both.
- Here's the punchline,
somehow at Sundance,
this movie, Ghoulies,
which I didn't know about,
but then like in this weekend it became
the most important thing in my life,
(Strauss laughs)
so then, a couple months later
we go to Strauss's house for
this event or what have you,
somehow not a lot of people are left
and somehow me and Ben are,
somehow it gets referenced,
Ghoulies, like we say something,
like it's the inside joke, it's the meme,
and Strauss goes, I made that movie.
(laughs)
Which to this day, is a top 10,
Strauss and I have not spent
a whole lot of time together,
we have a lot of mutual friends,
I have have an enormous
amount of admiration from him,
from afar, I'm gonna let him paint
a five minute context of his career
and then we'll do some
Q&A because he's gonna
help a lot of entrepreneurs, and then
anything else, Strauss, on your mind.
I'd love to know anything
that you wanna talk about.
But the Ghoulies thing is a top 10 moment.
Like from the heat, I think
everybody can associate
with this, you're friends,
random shit becomes
something you all talk about,
this was like white hot.
Like I basically said the word Ghoulies
87,000 times over a one week period,
and then one week later,
the man who fucking
green lit the movie, it was an amazing,
I don't know if you remember that Strauss.
- I do remember the story, you know
I'm probably gonna like
ruin the whole thing.
I made, I'm not sure I made --
- You made Ghoulies one?
- I made Goonies or Ghoulies, and I never
went to look to see which one was ours,
after we had this conversation.
- No, but I think you
had, if you made Goonies,
you would definitely know it.
Goonies is fucking the
greatest movie of all time.
- Well we made either Goonies
or Ghoulies, but anyhow.
- I think you made Ghoulies.
- All right, we made the worst --
- [Gary] Yeah you made Ghoulies.
- Whichever one was worse,
that was the one we made.
- That's the one you made.
- Okay good.
- Yeah we were not talking about Goonies.
What I think is actually a
top 10 movie of all time.
- No, I would have
remembered making any, oh no,
we didn't make a Steven Spielberg movie.
- No, you made Ghoulies.
- I barely met Steven Spielberg.
- You made Ghoulies, which is a movie
that nobody, Pete, what's
goin on, you got something?
Yes, yeah, it was, anyway, nonetheless.
- It does look familiar, anyway.
- So for everybody who's watching,
there's a ton of entrepreneurs,
lot of business people,
why don't you give everybody
a three minute like,
comic book episode one, who you are,
your career, a little bit about you?
- So on the career side, I always wanted
to be in the entertainment
business from growing up
for no particular reason.
- Where'd you grow up?
- I grew up in Boston,
and then New Jersey.
- What part of Jersey?
- South Orange.
- Love it, very close to WineLibrary.
My wine store was in
Springfield, Short Hills.
- [Strauss] Very close.
- Very close, go ahead.
- And I went to Wesley in undergrad,
I went right to grad school out of college
because I didn't wanna work, and I figured
couple more years in
school, and I was trying
to figure out how to
get into entertainment,
and a friend of a friend helped me get
my first job in entertainment, which was
a summer internship in Viacom.
And I worked there, I
had an amazing summer.
Met some people, that led
to my first full time job
which was at Columbia
Pictures Television in sales.
Which wasn't really what I had in mind.
I wanted to run a movie studio,
but okay, good place to start.
- But flat out, at that young of an age,
you're like that's what I wanna do.
- Oh I knew I wanted to run a movie studio
when I was five years
old, and I didn't even --
- Really, how did you
even know that existed?
- How did I even know,
I didn't even watch,
I wasn't allowed to go to
the movies particularly.
- You heard parents talking about it?
- No, it was completely made
up, my dad was a lawyer.
So, no clue, but I was committed to it.
(laughing)
- So real quick, just one more time,
because I need to rewind
that, you're not sure
because you were young how it got
into your zeitgeist, but you immediately
became committed to it?
- Yeah I think I had some sense
that it was like very glamorous
and that you could be like.
- But at five you cared
about the girls already?
- I think it was more about the money.
- God, respect.
One or the other, I
guessed wrong, keep going.
- Little did I know.
There are better ways to make money.
Anyhow I got recruited from Columbia
to go to what was then the largest
Home Entertainment Company, Vestron.
It's the early days of home entertainment.
That's how long ago it was,
and they were launching
a motion picture initiative and I became
the president of the company
like nine months later.
- How old were you at the time?
- I was 29, so I was basically
three years out of school.
And to say that I didn't know anything
is a gross understatement, I used to say,
my friends were like, well
this is a public company
and it was the biggest independent,
and their question was, well why would you
be president of this company?
And my answer was, well definitely not
competent for the job but I'm definitely
glad they gave it to me, so I did that --
- And then, you know at this point,
for a lot of people who are listening,
these days, 29 having a big company
or a big job, not insane.
- Wasn't then either, in
the entertainment business.
It's always been a business
that gave young people
opportunities early, no it was definitely,
I mean, you know it was precocious
but first of all, an
old person talking about
what it was like to but
young and successful
is pathetic, so I'm not gonna talk
too much about that, but no, you know
Barry Diller was in his early 30s when
he was chairman of Paramount.
So it was not at all unheard
of for successful people.
That went really well
because the first picture
I green lit became the highest grossing
independent film of all
time, which I do remember,
which was Dirty Dancing.
- And then that's that.
- You know, we made a
bunch of other movies,
there were some that did very well --
- Ghoulies.
I remember this is how the
conversation went down.
No, no, you made Ghoulies.
- I know you're committed to it,
but I just don't want people to like --
- Look it up.
- People are gonna be, if
it's not a Vestron movie,
I completely made it up.
And now Gary's like, it
ruined the rest of his night.
- Strauss, this is like
literally one of my
top 10 favorite stories.
- So it either was or it was
not distributed by Vestron
and I just don't wanna get the ugly email
saying I made that movie, how
can you take credit for it?
So.
- Who made it, tri-bloo-gah?
- But was it distributed by Vestron?
Yeah, you gotta figure, or who's catalog
is it in now, and then I could tell you.
Anyway, moving on, that went pretty well.
I was recruited from
there to become president
of 20th Century Fox.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- Was president of Fox,
that was a great run.
We had a whole bunch of hits, so after
being in the movie
business for seven years,
I really sort of revised my goal,
as having met what I thought
was a very long term goal
pretty quickly, and I decided to revise
my goal to say I really wanna do something
that's in entertainment,
but also entrepreneurial.
And I sort of surveyed the landscape.
And this is in 1993, and I said,
you know I think video games are gonna
become a huge entertainment business.
And I went to a company
called Crystal Dynamics
which was a pre-revenue video game company
as the first CEO, built that company up.
And then after we'd sort of got it
to a critical mass, I left to do
a turnaround of a huge record company
back in the days when
that wasn't an oxymoron.
That was called DMG, that went super well.
Took it from last place
to nearly first place.
Would have been first place,
but one and two merged.
So we were second place, but you know
it was a great result we had a lot
of great hits and turned around
the RCA label and other things.
And then I revised my goals once again
and said okay, my goal now is to run
a diversified media
company that's supercharged
by digital technology, and that was --
- What year was that?
- That was '01, and that was considered
somewhat out there, I mean,
people had gotten the memo
on digital technology, but I was
always seen as the new media person.
- And this was post April 2000
where things melted, right?
- Yeah, so, that's right.
- And you saw it as the opportunity.
- I saw it as an opportunity.
I mean most people thought
it was a terrible time.
My view is that there's never a good time,
there's no time when
you're starting a business
and you look around and say, wow,
this is an awesome time, it's always hard.
But it was the time when I was ready.
And I was done working for other people.
And so we started what has become ZMC.
And we had just, it's always
fun to tell these stories.
So, we had no offices, no capital,
no people, not really a business plan,
and I started the business
with $300,000 of my own money.
So for the last 18 years, we've been
building up that company, and today
we have assets in the
many billions of dollars
and very little debt, a great deal
of cash, and we own a
number of leading companies
in the media, communications --
- Like?
- And entertainment business.
Well our biggest company
is Take-Two Interactive,
which is a leading video game company,
the third largest, with
titles like Grand Theft Auto
and Red Dead Redemption,
NBA2K, Borderlands,
BioShock, Civilization and many others.
We own, with partners, 9
Story, which is a leading
Canadian based animation company.
Great hits and great titles, we have
an investment in a company
called Dynasty Sports.
We own IT Renew, which is
a so-called ITAD company.
It's a pretty arcane part
of the data center space.
We're big believers in the growth of data.
We own Cannella which is a leading
direct response television
advertising company.
AdThrive, a digital advertising company,
and a number of other interests.
- And what's happening with
your day-to-day these days
within that ecosystem?
- My day-to-day is I'm a partner at ZMC
and I'm the chief executive of Take-Two.
But Take-Two is a part of
ZMC, so I have the luxury
that I'm able to both invest and operate
in the media business, and I am able to,
our entire thesis is
based around the notion
that technology will continue to transform
and inform media and entertainment.
And we only invest behind that thesis.
And the reason that we've never suffered
a loss, and we've been able to grow
a very significant business from nothing,
at least so far, is because we don't
look at what's happening tomorrow
or next quarter, or a year, we look
five, 10, 15 20 years down the road.
And so far we haven't gotten it wrong.
So in '01, people in our business,
and we did have access to capital
or we couldn't have
bought these companies.
People in our business
were buying newspapers,
consumer magazines, and that was sexy
and appealing and we didn't do those deals
because we thought print was compromised.
And of course we were
right, we did however,
by an online market research company
before that was sexy, and obviously took
over a video game company in '07
that was very nearly bankrupt.
And the perception was that company
was at no chance of making it.
That companies market cap
today is about $10 billion.
- What's kind of most
exciting you right now
as you look out five, 10, 15 years?
- I think, this is just the beginning.
So for a lot of people, a
lot of people think that,
and I just heard this at a conference.
You know, we've kind of established
what the internet can do, we've kind of
established what digital
technology can do,
it's all gonna settle down,
and now the move forward
in digitally driven media
will be evolutionary
not revolutionary, I completely disagree.
I think the next 30 or 40 years
will be the most exciting time
that the media business has ever seen.
And you will see it in every part,
whether it's B2B, which we're in
or B2C, which we're in,
or pure entertainment,
which we're in, or
infrastructure, which we're in.
And the reason I believe in that,
is several things --
- History.
- Well first is history right --
- But honestly, right?
I mean that's the answer.
- Yeah I mean in the 1880's you know,
the head of the U.S. Patent Office
said I think pretty much
everything has been invented.
- That's it.
- So you know --
- You just know what humans do.
- Yeah we just keep inventing.
- Either their framework or perspective
doesn't allow them to historically
understand the context,
or they are financially
invested in the outcome
that comes out of their mouth.
- And often, frankly,
emotionally invested.
- 100%.
- Because everyone's financially invested
in staying ahead of change.
It's more emotionally invested.
Change scares a lot of people.
- But I think you'll
appreciate this right,
like to me, I'm of course
financially invested
in all of the things I do, however
because I'm an entrepreneur, I'm putting
my money where my mouth is, versus hoping
that the things maintains for the next
27 months because I need to
sell my stock at 27 months
and go do what I wanna
do personally after that.
- Yeah, that's a horrible way to live.
By the way, whenever people give me a
story like that, I'm like,
well here's the problem
with that plan, you could walk outside
and get hit by a truck tomorrow.
You can't even be careful
about delaying things for that.
So anyway, I think you
know, if you believe
in Moore's Law, which
I do, you believe that
whatever data consumption
you wanna project
five years from now,
aggregate data consumption,
you're wrong, it will be more.
- Couldn't agree more.
- You wanna project what
devices will look like.
So Nick's holding an iPhone,
I don't know which one.
Looks like a nine.
- If it's mine it's new.
- All right, or a 10.
So that form factor, in 10 years,
we'll look back on that form factor
and we will think it's really funny.
Looking at a couple cameras in here,
these form factors will look
really funny in 10 years.
- I just don't understand
that people don't understand.
It's history.
- Right, so --
- You know how rad as
fuck the Walkman was?
I know you do.
- Well yeah, of course.
- And like it was just the crazy --
- You just couldn't believe it.
- The Razor phone was the single
most important status item,
Seth you're old enough?
I'm impressed, like yeah, people are
unbelievably confused about
how it actually works.
- So what we do, is we look at the world
and we try to think about where
that's gonna be in five or 10 years.
And then, to the point about preservation
versus innovation or disintermediation,
we gotta be the ones to
disintermediate ourselves.
- 100%
- And that's a very hard task.
But it you're worried
about cannibalization
in your core business, you should be
the one cannibalizing your core business.
Or someone else will do it for you.
- Something I said to
a buddy a long time ago
that I use a lot, it was
the first time I said it
and I'll never forget I said it,
I said look I'd rather
put myself out of business
then let somebody else do it for me.
- [Strauss] Exactly.
- It's exactly right.
- When I got to the
record business in '94,
the first things we
did was launch websites
which was innovative,
and start thinking about
how we can do digital distribution.
By the way we didn't do such a great job
but we were trying really hard.
And we weren't surprised
when the Napsters came along.
We were prepared for it and we were
in the best position from anyone.
- What do you think about blockchain?
Forget about bitcoin and all
of that stuff, blockchain.
- Look, I think the notion
of a widely distributed
network for computing is fine, the problem
with the blockchain technology is
so far anyway, for you to create
the additional nodes you have to create
an incentive for people
to create the nodes.
And so far the incentive
has been currency.
- [Gary] That's right.
- And so if you have
something on the one hand
that has no owner and
is highly distributed,
on the other hand has no
built-in incentive, bit of a question.
The internet had a built in incentive.
Which is, I wanna express myself.
Or I wanna transact, or I wanna
have you come see something.
- It was human.
- But it's hard to know in the absence
of currency how you're gonna
make the blockchain work.
And then when companies talk about it
I'm convinced, when
big, big, big companies
are, I mean, people talk to us about
it in the game space all the time.
I wanna apply blockchain technology
to the video game business, I'm like,
please tell me how that
works, and it's not sarcastic.
I'm very interested.
- You just know that
they're putting hyperbole
around the statement,
I agree with you 100%.
- And so right now, like do
I believe in crypto currency?
I don't, and I know there
are plenty of people that do.
My attitude is, I believe in speculations.
They exist all the time, but any time
a so-called currency goes from $10
to $20,000 to $3,600 in the space of like,
my recent memory,
(Gary laughs)
that's not a currency,
it's something else,
it's not a currency, and for people
who transact outside a legitimate economy
they don't really care, because their
margins are so huge that
what they care about
is private transactions,
but for the rest of us,
like I have a really high margin
in most of my businesses, but I don't
have a sufficient margin to offset
that kind of currency swing.
- I understand.
- So I'm not a believer
at all in crypto currency.
- What about sports betting?
- I'm a huge believer in sports,
well first of all, it's a little late
in the day since the U.S. Government said
"we believe in it".
We're taking it from
the Federal government
saying it's okay, to
the states regulating it
in a way that works, will be complicated.
And then you've got a very powerful --
- I grew up in the liquor business,
so between cannabis and sports betting,
two things in the macro
I deeply believe in.
- Right but micro's different.
And so you've got massive lobbies,
very powerful lobbies, who've proven,
by the way that they can affect
a legislation of late, who have a --
- Not just of late, I'm they're ...
- Right, but in the casino business where,
so what do I believe, that if you're
already in the casino
business in the U.S.,
will you be able to engage
in broadly distributed,
digitally driven sports betting?
Yes, do I believe that
we as a non-regulated,
non-gaming company can
take our sports titles
and turn them into gaming opportunities?
It would be wonderful to believe that,
and if I were in the business of promoting
our security publicly I would say yes.
I think the answer is that the opportunity
may exist, but there are a
lot of regulatory hurdles.
There are obviously far fewer
of them internationally.
- Talk to me about,
actually I'm gonna ask you
a question that I'm curious about.
So I've been really enjoying,
similar to blockchain
and cannabis, and sports betting,
the notion of eSports teams,
watching a lot of people
deploy the logic around something,
you know this is where I get interested.
I think this is from afar,
and you know it's very clear
to me, listening to you,
there's a lot of things
that we cross over in agreeing on.
I'm fascinated by people's inability
to synthesize things in
lieu of what they hope
or emotionally or
financially want to happen.
Watching people deploy eSports strategies
in today's environments, fascinating
because much like what you did to whoever
says to you, we're gonna
do this blockchain thing,
I always say the same thing, I'm like,
please explain to me why you think
League of Legends is like the
Major League Baseball system.
And when you get into even a basic
first question, and you watch
people dance in front of you,
now that I've got a better framework
of how you process, and it's probably why
I like you, you know, what's your take
on the eSports ecosystem
around the IP holders
versus how the teams think they're
gonna conglomerate the power?
- So we're in the business, right?
And we eat our own cooking, but our view
is that like major sports,
we believe in eSports.
There are 250 million
people who watch eSports.
There are a whole bunch
of people who are playing.
- You're preaching.
- So for sure it's real, it is however,
the League of Legends business,
and it's a billion dollar business.
And in our world, video
game business alone,
never mind the media
business, video game business
is a $130 billion a year currently.
Esports is a billion dollars,
it's a teeny little business
and the bulk of the market
is League of Legends.
And I say that as a competitor,
we have the NBA2K league.
So I think they'll be somewhere between
three and seven powerful eSports
that will develop in the same way
that there are between three and seven
professional sports
leagues that truly matter.
You know, you've got
football, you've got baseball,
you've got soccer, especially worldwide.
- So you believe some of these IPs
will come out, really lock in --
- Absolutely and will create --
- And then will become --
- And they'll become very valuable.
- And do you think teams will be able to
sit on top and play in
all of them, individual?
- So I don't see a world,
and this is perhaps wrong,
because it's just
speculative, where you --
- The good news is for all the things
we've been right about, we've been wrong.
- Many times, right, and
when I say to people actually
when they ask my advice,
especially entrepreneurs,
this is one person's advice.
But if you ask the great entrepreneurs
if when they talk to
people about their ideas
people all said high five, that's awesome,
that didn't happen, so you
shouldn't listen to my ideas.
If you truly believe, you should go do it.
But in the case of eSports,
I have to eat my own cooking.
I'm betting on it, I'm paying for it.
So what we said is, look, people love
playing NBA2K it's the
biggest sports title
in the U.S., has been for years.
People love competing in NBA2K,
they're doing it anyhow, so wouldn't
it be sensible to have teams that compete
at NBA2K and then a broadcast if you will,
we're on Twitch, those games, that seems
to stand to reason, and so
that's why we're going for it.
Do I think those teams should be
both NBA2K and League of Legends --
- And Overwatch --
- And Overwatch, there's no real analogy
for that in professional sports.
I'm a little skeptical,
I think if you wanna
be the best NBA2K player --
- But Deion Sanders might
just pop out of the side here.
- Yeah, it's possible, and
it's a different skill set.
- No question.
- But I think if you wanna be the best
NBA2K player, you're probably not also
gonna be the best Overwatch player.
- What I think is most interesting
about what you're saying,
to me, is will they bake?
Will three to seven titles bake,
or because of the notion of the framework
if the different thing,
creating a ball-centric sport
which is what we're coming from,
I mean literally look,
EA just has a hit in a,
will it be more like the movie
and television business
where in perpetuity
there will be games that capture three,
four, five, years, or are you saying
Marvel, Star Wars, you know there's --
- I'm more saying that.
- I know that's what you're saying.
- But it's a sport.
- But in Marvel and Star
Wars, there still will
be a Forrest Gump, there
still will be, right?
And so it'll be interesting
if I'm actually,
just literally as you're talking,
I'm like, oh, so maybe it
bakes three to seven and,
or maybe it bakes six and you're always
in an environment where
another four are always
getting five year runs and seven year runs
versus the kind of five
that get a forty year run.
I don't know.
- I'm skeptical only because team play,
and watching team play seems to cluster
around these very ancient forms.
But you know what, this
could be an example
where history just isn't
a guide of the future.
Because after all, League of Legends
does not look like hockey, football,
baseball or you know,
soccer, so it remains
to be seen, I feel very, obviously,
very good about our
bet, because I feel like
it's right in the pocket.
- You're doubling down, yeah.
- Right in the pocket, but that's it,
that's all it is, we've had one season.
- If you're watching
on Instagram, Facebook,
put in your phone numbers,
Calvin's ready to call.
We have to give you an opportunity
to get some access to
this wonderful thinking.
You ready to do one, you got one?
Go ahead.
- Yeah, you can ask
personal questions too.
Not just business questions.
- I like business questions.
Is there anything you wanna
talk about that's personal?
- Oh no, anything you bring up.
- You know, I like trends,
I like macro thinking,
I love history, you know, I like the way
you're kind of story telling
because it's contextual.
(phone ringing)
Which I bet on context and human behavior.
It's not super complicated, I'm patient.
- [Recording] We are unable to
complete your call at this time.
- Mel you fucked up, we're
gonna go to the next call.
(laughs)
Actually speaking of that.
- Speaking of Mel?
- No, not Mel, hold this for a second,
speaking of some of or similarities,
how much do you get
excited about analyzing
things that are popping in culture?
Is that something you give a fuck about?
- Things that are popping
in culture? All the time.
- Cool, so that makes sense to me,
based on how we're
talking, give me something,
is there anything that's on your radar
right now that you're
like, "huh", or "hm".
- You know, I think --
- What's the last thing, so
like Slime with nine year olds
or K-Pop, like what's in the "hm".
- I would say "hm" has
been the most recent
social media apps that kids are using --
- TikTok?
- Yes, that I was not familiar with.
- But you know that's
musicly, reincarnation sure.
So, thoughts.
- I have a young guy who every month
comes in and shows me what's happening
in popular culture that
I wouldn't have run into.
- Smart.
Strauss on that note,
this is actually something
I think I know as well --
- He's one of our interns, he's great.
- On that note --
- By the way he had to
delete the inappropriate
stuff before he showed me.
- He thinks you would give a shit?
- I loved that, that was great.
- Yeah exactly, you do a
good job of that right,
like you do have, it's
funny you just said,
I don't know why that triggered me.
But it seems like all of a sudden my brain
just jiggered and I feel like I've
come across, over the last 10 years
three individuals that talk about
spending time with you or having lunch
with you or breakfast with you,
you're doing that game, huh?
- I spend about 25% of my time coaching
and mentoring people at all stages
of their career, all stages, including
people who are older than I, but it does
tend to skew younger, and I didn't do it
for any other reason except that
I make light entertainment for a living.
And I really thought it was important
to find some way to make a difference.
And it seemed that I could do that,
and so I had an open door, and when
you give an open door in a business
that's hard to break
into like entertainment,
you know what, people come in.
And so I gotta tell you, I didn't do it
for this reason, but I've developed
an extraordinary collection of friendships
from doing it, so it's actually
been amazingly worthwhile, and after all,
that's how you and I met, because Ben
brought you to my house.
- Yeah, 100%, 100%.
Who's this?
So TikTok's on your radar.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly,
and something next month
will be on my radar.
- What's interesting
about that in the macro
is it's people using
something to help them create.
- [Andrew] Hello?
- Who's this, Andrew.
- [Andrew] Andrew.
- Yes, you're Andrew, right?
- [Andrew] Yes (laughs)
- I'm Gary, Strauss is here too.
- [Andrew] Hey Gary.
- Say hello to Strauss.
- [Andrew] Hey Strauss, how you doing?
- I'm good how are you?
- [Andrew] Good, just about
to take my daughter home
but had to put my number up there,
had to tell you, Gary you've been
an inspiration to me, thank you very much
really appreciate it.
- Is there anything we can answer,
anything on your mind,
anything we can answer for you?
- [Andrew] So, I just created,
well, let me start off.
Been an entrepreneur for almost,
since I was like 19 I'm gonna say.
- Okay.
- [Andrew] My father's been a hustler,
you know, he sold pots,
he sold water filters,
he's always been telling me you know,
always hustle, hustle, hustle.
- Where did you grow up?
- [Andrew] Yeah, well, New York.
- Love it, keep going.
- [Andrew] New York, so one day I sat down
with my sister, we actually opened up
a liquor store.
- I know a lot about that.
Go ahead.
- [Andrew] Yeah, so.
- How's it going?
So wait, lay this out for me,
you and your sister just sit down
on the sofa in the living room and like
let's open a liquor store and boom
you open a liquor store?
- [Andrew] We've always
kind of thought about it
and it's actually a
place, a place opened up.
- That went out of business
and you just took it over.
- [Andrew] No, we just
started from scratch.
We didn't know shit about liquor stores.
- So how's it going?
- [Andrew] Not so good, not so good.
- Why, what's your hot
take, what's your early,
how long have you had it?
- [Andrew] Five years.
- What's your read, so not your hot take,
your like educated guess, five years in,
what's the struggle in your opinion?
- [Andrew] (sighs) to be honest with you,
just a lot of things, loss of customers,
just maybe us not buying enough liquor.
- That would do it.
- [Andrew] Just for cost and everything.
- Is your, you know one of the tough
things about the liquor
business in the North East,
specifically in New York and New Jersey
is it's much more of a price market
than people realize, it's hard
to differentiate when
people know what they want.
Especially if you sell liquor and beer.
One of the reasons I took my dad's
store from Shopper's Discount Liquors
to WineLibrary, was very
quickly as a 15 year old
I said oh shit, I am not
convincing this 80 year
old woman that walked
in, that's been drinking
Johnny Walker Black for 52 years
to try some other scotch that I could
make more money on, and the same
thing became real for me of
like Truck Driver Johnny,
he's fucking drinking Natty Light.
Like it's hard for me to move 'em.
On the wine side, there
was this exploratory
kind of, I don't know anything about wine,
I drink Kendall-Jackson
and Santa Margherita
and Silver Oak, but I'm very insecure
maybe you know something else,
what's this wine spectator Robert Parker.
And I found my creative opportunity.
And then once I understood
wine makers mattered,
I started painting pictures
and what picture painting
allowed me to do was
split up the business.
I sold everything everybody
knew about at cost.
I literally sold Budweiser, Schaefer,
Dewars White Label
Scotch, Santa Margherita,
everything that people
drank that they knew
that everybody knew, every brand
I sold at dead cost, and then I spent
every single cent of my energy, life,
that you would walk in because you knew
we sold Budweiser at
cost, or more importantly,
specifically to wine, you knew
that we sold Kendall-Jackson
and Santa Margherita
at dead cost, they were
the two most important
items, and I would intercept you
through my merchandising or actually
being on the floor at first because
we were a small company, and I would
try to story tell to
you why Santa Margherita
pinot grigio at 12.99 was overpriced,
which it was, which
having truth on your side
was great, and why you
needed to try this 9.99
pinot grigio, but oh
by the way I was making
$4 a bottle on that
versus zero on the 12.99.
And then when you tasted it, and you liked
it better, or at least
in the same ball park
I started building trust.
You're in a commodity business,
you have to create a differentiator.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- Instead of standing behind the register
and waiting for people to buy shit.
- [Andrew] Honestly, I'm
not scared to sell it.
We're about to sell it actually.
- Okay.
- [Andrew] I'm not scared to move on
to the next project, you know,
I actually do a little bit of everything.
I sell jewelry, I'm a local DJ.
- Look, I'm all about
being a Renaissance man
and I'm one, but one of the reasons
the liquor store might be fucking failing,
is because you're doing 87 things
which means you're doing no things.
- Yeah, you gotta focus.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- Especially early in a career.
- That's a good point.
Like to me, listen, I'm (sighs)
I love chaos, I'm doing 800 things.
- But you didn't start doing 800 things.
- That's right, and
anytime I know I'm about
to do something, I did VaynerMedia
head down for five years to
build a foundation to do things.
- I always tell people this.
We've got a lot of lines of business now.
We've got a bunch of companies.
Eight companies, and people say --
- [Gary] Andrew, thanks for
calling brother, good luck.
Hit me on the DM.
- [Andrew] No wait, hey.
- Oh, sorry Strauss, go ahead.
- [Andrew] Can I mention this one thing --
- Go.
- [Andrew] That's what I
called to tell you about.
I just started this new application
that I just made, it's
up on the iOS store.
It's for local DJs and
local photographers.
I feel like it's gonna
be the greatest thing.
- Of course because you're gonna build
a two way marketplace to help
people be discovered, right?
- [Andrew] Yes, yes.
- The hardest business in
the world that everybody
wants to build, that's why eBay and Uber
are trillion dollar companies,
you know, but go ahead.
- [Andrew] Yes, so my question was
how do I gain the trust for
my users to start signing up?
- You mean the supply, the actual DJs,
the actual, those people,
or the consumers to find?
- [Andrew] Yes, no just the actual DJs
because when they start signing up --
- I got it, I got it, my intuition.
My intuition on a limited context,
I have six minutes and
13 seconds into you,
I would go hand to hand
combat, go hand to hand combat,
localized, DM, meet people,
shake hands, kiss babies,
get those first 50 to 70 people.
People forget that Uber
was in San Francisco
for well over a year,
almost two full years
before they even came to New York, right.
Everybody wants to expand, just
where do you live right now?
- [Andrew] New York in Yonkers.
- Yonk, win fucking Yonkers.
One step at a time, I'm already impressed
that you got into the app store,
a lot to people talk, they dream,
I appreciate the execution,
not sure how you did it,
built it, this and that
win fucking Yonkers.
Win Westchester, let's just start there.
And how do you do that,
fucking go to Google
and go to Instagram and use hashtags
and five 50 to 500 local
players in your market
and go buy them some french fries.
Give them a free bottle of booze,
figure it the fuck out,
hand to hand combat.
- [Andrew] I wanna say the
name to my app before I leave.
- Go ahead, we'll give
it to you, go ahead.
- [Andrew] It's Evntly.
- Evntly?
- [Andrew] Yes.
- Good name too, all right brother.
- [Andrew] E-V-N-T-L-Y.
- I love the hustle brother, good luck.
- [Strauss] Good luck.
- [Andrew] All right, thank you.
- Strauss you were saying.
- A lot of entrepreneurs will come and say
you know I wanna have, I
don't wanna just do this thing
I wanna do this thing and
then I want that division
and then I want that
plan, and they'll outline
three or four goals at once, and you know
what I say is, I've never
seen an entrepreneur,
not once, who started
with more than one thing.
I've seen plenty who,
having started one thing
and made it successful moved on.
So I would say, you know,
as entrepreneurs go,
Bill Gates, pretty good entrepreneur.
He started with desktop operating systems
and he stuck with that for a long time.
- Long time.
Yeah, actually this is a good segue
because this is something
I'm passionate about.
Might be a good place
to take this back half
of this interview, entrepreneurship.
It's become a very
different thing than what
you and I knew it to be
for a very long time.
Right, I was a bad student, which was
unusual for immigrants from
the former Soviet Union.
All the kids, you know ...
I think a lot of Ls along the way
because I just couldn't be anything else.
I just didn't have it in me.
Baseball cards or
anything else, then wine,
blah, blah, blah, I
literally sat, sophomore year
in high school and would
read the wine spectator
cover to cover and that's
why I got Ds and Fs
in science, and so it was
just, it wasn't viable.
I was this poor student
and I was doing all these,
I was making $3,000 a
weekend selling baseball
cards but every parent of my friends
and every teacher told me
I was gonna be a loser.
There wasn't even a
framework in 1990 to '89
to see the world through
an entrepreneur's eyes.
We are very much not there now.
- That's right.
- We are now in the other
place where career students
have decided they're gonna be
the next Zuckerberg, right.
You know I'd love to get your perspective
on the state of the
union of entrepreneurship
through your eyes based on the way
I framed it up, are you, what
do you think's happening?
- It's easier to approach the world.
I mean you just talked to someone who owns
a liquor store who just got
an app in the app store.
And you know as you point
out maybe if he goes
and hustles and promotes,
it could take off.
Pretty crowded place, the app store,
thousands of new apps at all times.
- The joke I was making, I was just having
a little fun with you
but trying to educate,
two way marketplaces, I
mean that is 9,000 times
a day in my DM and email,
because what I like
is people scratch their own
itch, they see the pain.
They just don't realize
how difficult it is
to build a monster in that
space, but nonetheless.
- So I think you know,
it's always been hard
to build a business
that's highly successful.
It's still hard today.
I do think the world's a
little more forgiving today
of people who take non traditional paths.
- Because of the cost of entry?
- No, it's just gotten
a little more popular
because you know, really, really, really
smart people like Mark Zuckerberg don't
complete college and go on
to be hugely successful.
But in fairness, Bill Gates
didn't finish Harvard,
you know he's my age, so I think --
- Upfront costs, to get in
the game though, have changed.
- Yeah the upfront cost is way lower.
- And the scale to get
to the end consumer.
- But the opportunity for great
success is still the same.
- What about, you know I
apologize, micro success.
Something I'm getting
outrageously passionate about
and really the book
that put me on the map.
You know a lot of people are like hustle
and they need to take shots at me,
and I'm like did you read
it, because really what
I'm saying is my intuition, this is 2008,
is the way the Internet's
going, specifically on social
is there's a lot of people
making $69,000 a year
being thrilled being an expert
in Smurfs or selling jam
who are making 80, this was my thesis.
You could make 88,000 having
a job you don't love or 120,
or you could make 79, or maybe 140,
being the foremost experts of Star Trek,
and that's what played out.
- So that's for sure the
case, our company AdThrive
allows independent publishers
to make a great living.
Some of them actually
are immensely successful
and they become huge, for some people
it's the difference between making $20,000
in their spare time and
making $100,000 a year
which they can live
on, and live on nicely.
- Especially, and stress,
this is something that,
happiness has to be talked about more.
- So I ate lunch with
an entrepreneur today.
And he's in the fitness space, and he had
walked away from a very
big and successful career
as an actor to go into the fitness space
knowing full well he would likely,
permanently make less money
because it pleases him.
- Happiness.
- And it's what he loves to
do, and he's passionate about
it, and therefore he's great at it.
And it is his joy to spend his day
in the gym improving people's lives.
And no, he's not living horribly,
because he's so good at what he does.
You know what my feeling
is, you're really, really
good at what you do, generally speaking?
You'll make a living.
The other thing is most
people, not everyone,
most people are not, once they have food,
clothing, shelter, and
the ability to raise
and educate their kids, most people
don't care about incremental money.
In terms of what truly makes a
difference in your happiness.
Some people do, some people
do, most people don't.
- Especially if they can get into a place
where they can deal with outside judgment
and aren't so insecure
that they need things
to prove things to people,
usually they don't need it.
- When they're self motivated,
so when I coach people,
the question I start with
is, what is it that you want
that you truly want, not
that other people tell
you you should want --
- Not what you're trying
to prove to somebody else.
- Exactly, what is it
that you actually want?
And think about what that life looks like.
- Can I ask you a question?
For me it's very clear,
I love the game itself.
The process is so much more enjoyable
than the trophy, like do you
feel like you're a process guy?
- Well I'm an achievement
guy, I've decided.
I like doing hard things, and that's why,
if you look at what I
do, I do turnarounds,
I do really hard things in media.
Sometimes I think like I'm intentionally
the guy walking up the hill
with a backpack full of rocks
and if one happens to fall
out, I pick up another one.
If I run into you, I grab your rocks too.
So I'm not sure it's
always the healthiest.
- I got it.
- But I like doing super hard things
and then pointing, not
to others, to myself
that I was able to do that,
that means a lot to me.
Maybe too much to me, do
I care about the money
that comes with it?
I enjoy making money because
it's fun to make money.
It's certainly nice not to have
huge financial constraints, and I don't
wanna minimize that, but does it motivate
me day to day, no, achieving
interesting and hard
things motivates me, and
working in a field I love
motivates me, I love
media and entertainment.
And I love working with creative people
which is how I spend about half my day.
- [Gary] In the last two minutes here --
- That really matters to me.
- What did we not cover,
or is there anything
you'd like to talk about?
- I think I covered a lot of it.
There are lots of things
I look to talk about.
But I think you sort of
covered it towards the end.
Which is you know, what
are we all doing here?
And it's tempting to sort of focus on
you know, are you gonna be successful
or can you make it, or
will the liquor store
be successful, how can you
have hand to hand combat
to make your app successful, you know
I think the thing I like to talk about
is stepping back from them which is why
are you doing this, and you know,
if the answer to the question
is yes that worked out,
then what's the question.
If I say to you, you can have it,
it's gonna work, you know,
it'll be what you want.
How many people have
actually thought about,
well what exactly is that?
I would say the one thing
that I'm super proud of,
is that when I was really young,
I knew basically what I
wanted my life to look like
when I'm this age, and while of course
I couldn't have predicted it perfectly
but it's pretty close, and the other thing
is it's not for everyone,
it's not for everyone.
But it is for me, and I think,
one of the reasons I
feel some satisfaction
is not because I feel like I crushed it,
not like I feel like I figured it out
and certainly not because
I'm the most successful
person, I don't feel any of those things.
But I set out to have a certain life
that would work for me both
professionally and personally
and more or less that's what I got.
- Man, I gotta tell
you, when I tell people,
after wishing people
that I care about health,
boy, is self-awareness the next thing
that always populates
because once you map that
stuff can get real interesting.
- Yeah, and more peaceful.
- 100%, I appreciate
you being on the show.
- Thanks for having me.
- See ya guys, you keep asking questions.
We'll keep answering them.
Hey guys thank you so much for watching
my video on YouTube, I
wanted to jump in here
at the end, because I'm
working on a ridiculously
important project for me, and I have
a funny feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all, or know
anybody that drinks wine at all
please go to empathywines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription,
whether it's a three pack,
whether it's a six pack or
whether it's a whole case
of each for the year, if you
drink 35 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year
please sign up for Club
Empathy, this project
means the world to me, I
could really use your support.
(hip hop beat)